okay now the reason why I've got this
table of right is we've just been
working with derivatives right but
derivatives imply integrals don't they
okay and these are actually the results
that mainly get used but as you'll see
in a second it gets quite confusing but
I'm gonna put in table so let's just go
sign him in cause he must tan inverse
let's rehearse it the derivative of sine
inverse okay
what's it equal to these are the let's
start memorizing okay it's the positive
one it's increasing right so that's why
I go one on okay cos inverse it's
exactly the same as a value but it's the
decreasing version because cos is going
down okay okay when we do tan inverse
because the derivative of tan is SEC
squared right that's why we didn't need
to pull out the square root business
right so that's how I remember that this
is one on one plus x squared with those
square roots are involved okay so what
integrals do we get out of this well I'm
gonna go from the right-hand side to the
left-hand side yeah so my integral of
one falling the square root of one minus
x squared with respect to X okay will be
equal to sine inverse of X plus my
constant okay now this is really
interesting okay
cuz when you have a look at this if
you've got this question maybe three
weeks ago okay when we started off doing
integration properly okay if you look at
that you'd probably guess maybe it's
like something to do with you know chain
rule for a log function or maybe it's
something like I've got to get this out
of the denominator and it'll just be a
polynomial some kind but it's it's not
an awful it lands you an inverse trig
which is kind of weird okay all right
now I'm gonna skip this road for a
second you'll see why in a minute
let's do tan inverse so if I integrate
one on one plus x squared with respect
to X I'm going to get tan inverse
okay these are fine now let me come back
to this one in the middle I could write
the integral of minus one over
ba-ba-ba-ba-ba equals cos inverse plus e
I could write that okay what I know is
that that integral that I form out of
this is very similar to this integral is
it not what's the difference the
difference is just a constant
coefficient a constant coefficient okay
so instead of writing down you know the
square the integral of that with a minus
sign on the front edge open something
different I'm going to take this
function here the same integral from the
first and say if I were to integrate
this I actually don't have to land on
sine inverse okay
if I want to if the question makes it
more convenient for me to do so I can
land on minus cos inverse plus my
constant okay can you see what's going
on here
sine inverse and minus cos inverse
here's sine inverse and here's minus cos
inverse sorry that's regular closet it's
down below so it's actually going to be
over here what's the difference between
these two and the answer is a constant
you just moved up or down I mean in this
case if the constant was zero you know
this isn't my expand to right
I'm sure this is kind of strange to us
right you can integrate the one thing
and land on two equally legitimate
options depending on how a question
suits okay and the difference is the
constant okay now let's bring in the one
two chain rule okay so if I integrate
remember what I had underneath the
square root right I had that a squared
coming in which simplified things okay
so if I had the square root of a squared
minus x squared okay that's gonna be and
do you remember what I started off with
what I actually differentiate it was X
on a plus my clothes then okay now just
like I did in the previous column I
don't have to land on signing us I can
land on - Cosima's if I like
if it's more convenient to me okay one
last one if I have a squared plus x
squared with respect to X that's going
to leave me on one over a tan inverse
okay now if you are like me you think
far out this is worse than XI extensions
okay remember the four main treatments
for saline cause you're like these all
will look exactly the same
how am I supposed to remember these
until them apart the answer is we kind
of don't because you get a table of
standard integrals that'll give you
these results over here okay we should
kind over the important ones right most
people have no trouble remembering the
derivatives it's when you get the
integrals that people start to get
confused particularly because these look
so similar to each other okay so you get
this you'll also so these are near the
bottom because you were quite a few
integrals by this stage okay you'll also
notice there are some ones with logs
right at the very bottom of the page but
we're going to cover those in topic
eight which is actually after this exam
okay so you can look them but don't
freak out that you're like I don't know
what those are equal to okay okay now a
quick question you have a table of
standard integrals right so therefore do
you not need to know any of these answer
if you need to refer your table standard
integrals repeatedly to do these kinds
of questions number one probably means
you're gonna be very error-prone because
you just don't know well enough number
two looking at Taylor Santa Cruz in the
middle of an exam we are rushing just to
finish the exam you know ain't nobody
got time for that okay so you really
still actually need to know them but you
can kind of use this as a safety net
it's a little bit like your calculator
for those expansions we looked at
yesterday
okay can you use it yes should you
actually solve a question that way
probably not but use it as a backup that
makes sense